Cho xem bóng đá đến với kênh tin học Đỗ
Bảo Nam Block đi đường hôm nay đâu bán
hàng blog chia sẻ với bạn cách ẩn hiện
thành công cụ trong Word trên tất cả các
phiên bản
để ẩn hoặc hiện thanh công cụ trong Word
Bạn có nhiều cách thực hiện và trong
video này đâu Bảo Nam plus chia sẻ nhanh
như bạn 2 cách để ẩn hoặc hiện thành
công cụ tốt nhất bạn dùng phím tắt đó là
consol + F1 Ví dụ ở đây mình sẽ nhấn tổ
phím là control + F1 trên bàn phím
thì bạn thấy thanh công cụ đã bị ẩn đi
và chỉ còn Manu
Nếu để hiển thị lại thì bạn tiếp tục
nhấn tổ hợp phím Control + F1 như vậy
anh công cụ đã được hiển thị ra lại
trong trường hợp bạn muốn ẩn hoàn toàn
các thanh công cụ và Manu này theo bạn
kích vào cái icon mũi tên ở
e-mall sẽ
chọn phone remote
như vậy toàn bộ thành công cụ cũng như
là marou đã được ẩn đi
nếu bạn muốn hiển thị lại cái thanh công
cụ này thì bạn kích vào cái dấu ba chấm
để vào tự chọn hoa kích tiếp vào cái mũi
tên cho Owen sale 4U
ở
trong trường hợp cái thanh công cụ ẩn đi
chỉ còn cái Manu này Ví dụ ở đây mình sẽ
chọn đâu tackling
mà bạn muốn hiển thị
em gái cũng cụ răng thì cách bạn có thể
dùng đó là kết chuột phải vào menu và
chọn cái cospak glass-bone
ở đây mình sẽ có chuột phải vào menu bạn
có thể kích chuột phải vào một vị trí
bất kì nào ở lúc này
Ví dụ mình sẽ có định vào cái phần gần
do này
quả tích ở cái ròng cuối cùng nó đi
Hình như vậy anh công cụ đã được hiển
thị cho này
đối với một số văn bản cô hơn thì bạn
không nhìn thấy cái hình mũi tên như ở
trên màn hình
thì khi đó bạn sẽ nhìn thấy có một cái
icon mũi tên ở
phía trên công như thế này thì bạn chỉ
làm kết và anh từ này
sao lắm chọn auto 2 mol để
hiển thị toàn màn hình của giao diện web
nếu như bạn muốn chỉ hiển thị menu thì
bạn chọn sáng tác Ừ nếu như bạn muốn
hiền iPhone toàn bộ thành công cụ như
bật nhìn thấy ở đây thì bạn chọn sâu các
em comment
nói như vậy Ở nội dung video vừa rồi nó
bảo Nam blog vừa chia sẻ nhanh với bạn
cách ẩn hoặc hiện Anh công cụ trong Word
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích bạn hay nhất truyện còn ai và chia
sẻ video để ủng hộ đó bà Nam bất đồng
thời Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ bà Nam
lúc bạn anh nhấp chuột vào nút đăng ký
và chọn hình chuông
nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và nhận thêm
các video cũng từ đỗ bà Nam và Đốc Xin
cảm ơn các bạn
Ngoài ra bạn có thể tìm kiếm trên Google
với từ khóa đỗ vào năm lúc
và truy cập website đô Bảo Nam club.com
hoặc kênh YouTube nó bàn ăn Vlog để xem
thêm các video vui thủ thuật máy tính
tay Chrome của dơ
cách sử dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint vân vân và bạn có thể truy
cập Website là đỗ Bà Năm blach.com để
cập nhật những bài viết hữu ích mới nhất
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và
hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các video tiếp theo